hey everybody guess what time it is time
for the movie retrospective yeah now
this is the second week of the patreon
poll and uh this one came out on top
newer movie um this one was like i think
it beat last man on earth by one vote or
two votes or something like that but
this is a movie from 2008 called lake
mungo so this one got the most votes
now i will say
i first heard of this movie even though
it came out you know a while back
i first heard about this movie because
periodically i kind of go on things
where it's like you know best underrated
movies of like the last 20 years best
you know that you haven't seen or
whatever so i try to get like all these
underseen gems so this was one that came
up on a bunch of people's lists and then
i noticed that toby had it so i sat and
watched it by myself one weekend and i
really
really dug it
now i will say it's a psychological
horror it's a ghost story
and it's kind of like
it's a real slow burn
um
but it has some like really really great
like creepy
really creepy imagery and i really like
the way that it unfolds because
if you didn't know and like i said i'm
going to
spoil this movie so um
you know if you haven't seen it yet it's
on tubey you can go watch it for free um
because it's really really hard to talk
about without talking about like all the
twists that happen in the documentary it
feels like a real documentary it really
does they nailed it if the tone if i had
thought it was real i would have enjoyed
it a lot more i think but going into it
knowing it was a mockumentary
for me
i find it just to be kind of dry it's a
real good movie it's not necessarily my
kind of movie i mean everything's to
people's tastes yeah you know
this seems to be one that really like i
said a lot of horror fans really are
into it but like i said you have to be
into slow burn you have to be
willing to get into
uh you know the emotions of the family
like at the center of it because that's
kind of like a big part of what makes it
creepy
is um you know just all the stuff that
happens in this family so like we said
it's a mockumentary probably the best
mockumentary in the sense that if you
didn't know that it wasn't real
um you would never guess you know what
i'm saying and actually the first time
that i watched it i was pretty sure it
wasn't real like i thought i heard that
it wasn't real but then when i was
watching it i wasn't sure like you know
what i mean that's how good it came
across yeah because the guy that did it
joel anderson he wrote and directed it
this might be his only movie
weirdly he had been working on since
2005. he wanted to do another movie but
i guess um it needed too big a budget he
couldn't find investors so he wanted to
do like a smaller one this is an
australian movie he also got some uh you
know
just kidding he's [__] driving me
crazy that's cool what are you doing
pokey no
she wants attention she's like she wants
to dance and she's getting it i want to
play with the paper she's stopped
getting into the shirt shipment i know
she's like tearing them up yeah
please doesn't tear all the [__] yeah
those are addressed already and ready to
go so she can't tear them up yeah that's
you can tear up the empty one if you
want actually there's one in there
that's like empty that you can go ahead
and attack she is the child from
mandalorian exactly she is she's a child
man lauren she's very miserable she's
gonna make a child [__] picture with
the the put her head on that would be
easy i think
she's got that little face ears and
everything yeah she's gonna have little
ears but yeah so this is an australian
film so it was partly funded by the
australian government because he got
like a grant to make it with because it
was like a you know a lower budget film
one interesting thing that he did now to
get
the realism for the mockumentary feel
he not only got
actors that you know weren't super well
known like he got like some kind of you
know more obscure actors
he also didn't really have
a written script per se he had an
outline of how the story was going to go
and then he basically
interviewed the people the actors as
though they were real people so when you
periodically hear a voice uh asking you
know the people in the movie questions
that's the writer director so um so it's
pretty much all improvised they just had
an outline of how the story was supposed
to go you know how the story beats were
supposed to be and they um you know just
kind of like improvised from there so it
would be like more
real
they also got people that were not real
um
quirky or they weren't real they were
just like regular normal people that
were like very relatable
so in that sense it came across and
watching it again like yesterday
it came across almost like the new
unsolved mysteries or some of those like
netflix documentaries about like a true
crime or something it comes off like
almost exactly like that so like i said
if you didn't know that it wasn't real
then you would you might be fooled by it
you know what i mean because it keeps it
it has it goes into like supernatural
[__] later but it keeps it very low key
so it's like it could be you know what i
mean it could be it could be real yeah
you know
appreciating the movie it has a lot to
do with [__]
your damn mental state at the time
maybe had i been in a different mood at
the time that i watched it maybe i would
have enjoyed it more um when it comes to
mockumentaries i'm more into stuff like
spinal tap where the shit's [__]
funny yeah and it's and you know it's
it's a mockumentary it's just
but this is you know i'm not saying
anything bad about it it's just i you
know maybe it was my mental state at the
time it was it's a well-made
mockumentary i think people might enjoy
it i think it just depends a lot of
people seem to it really has um as far
as i know on imdb it has a 94 uh fresh
rating so there you go and like i said a
lot of horror reviewers really seem to
dig it and it's like underrated now like
i said it's a very slow burn it's very
low key
um it's kind of it's also very
sad like it's almost more
it's not like overtly scary but it has
like some really creepy or like an
unsettling kind of vibe to it and some
of the imagery is very unsettling um so
it's more of like
that type of thing where it's just kind
of like subdued but in a way i think
that makes it creepier because it's more
realistic
like some of the stuff that happens in
it is like supernatural but not so out
there that you're like oh that couldn't
happen real good special effects when
they show dead bodies that it looks real
yeah that body looked pretty uh pretty
real so let's kind of talk like i said
i'm gonna spoil this so if you haven't
seen it please go to 2b and watch it um
you know don't yell at me because it's
it's hard to discuss it any further
without saying what actually happens in
it um and but i will say that if you
want to see it and you know go watch it
because
it's much better to watch it when you
don't know what's going to happen like
because the first time i watched it all
i knew was it was a mockumentary uh
about a girl that died and then creepy
[__] started to happen that's literally
all i knew
so it's it's much more effective if you
go into it not knowing
what's gonna happen like what all the
twists and everything like that because
it does have a couple of twists in it
so basically the setup at the very
beginning
this comes across like
um there's this family the palmers
and uh in australia because like i said
that's where this movie was made
and they have a 16 year old daughter
named alice now they're all like at this
damn at this place called ararat like
for a vacation it's you know it's
december but that's summer in australia
um and she disappears now they don't
know where she at she is they have like
all they have news footage they have
interview with the interviews with the
parents and the brother and everything
like that and they're kind of talking
about it in the past like as you know as
what happens they were talking about how
they felt about it and uh having to go
home and not knowing where she was
so then you find out they show through
more news footage and more interviews
with family members and friends and
stuff like that you find out that a
couple days later um her body or maybe a
couple weeks later i don't remember
but her body is found in the lake by
this dam so she was uh she had drowned
so they pulled her out and uh like you
said the dead body effect
very realistic
it's like a very disturbing looking yeah
it looks good looks like a real dead
bite it's been on the water it really
does like it looks like pretty nasty um
so the dad identifies the body as his
daughter
the uh because he feels like the mom
shouldn't have to the mom's name is june
the dad's name is russell i think and
the son's name is maddie
or matt
and
so then
a few days after
the body is found
matthew starts reporting that like some
creepy [__] has started to happen around
the house like they all say we you know
we started hearing all these funny
noises you know like creaking like your
basic haunting kind of stuff
so then matthew gets uh an interest in
he i think they show a scene at the
beginning where he's like a
projectionist like at a theater so he
starts to get really interested in
photography and he starts taking
pictures um all around the house all
around the yard and all this other kind
of stuff now it comes to pass that some
of the photographs he has taken appear
to show
his dead sister
kind of maybe like over in the corner or
over like he takes a picture of the
backyard and it looks very much
like alice is standing there like a
ghostly version of her but it's not i
love the way that they did
the uh the photographs and the footage
of everything like that because it's
almost like
you could almost say that it's like oh
maybe there's nothing there but you know
what i mean they just do it like that so
it's like a lot more realistic
which to me like makes it creepier
so
all these like photographs and [__] like
that star command and so the mom is
sitting there thinking well you know
alice is still in the house like she's
still haunting the house
because she keeps coming out on all
these pictures
so she um
she's uh she calls up this psychic i
guess he's kind of like famous in the
tell like he's been on the radio and
stuff so the mom decides she's gonna
call up the psychic to see like why
alice is still hanging around
and they have like a seance and all this
other [__] and um it does like it does
appear that nothing really happens at
the seance but it does appear that when
they watch the footage later it looks
like alice is like standing in the
background like of the video and it's
really cool the way they do
um you know the shots because they just
have like the the footage and it's like
really shitty it looks like old you know
vhs footage or something and then you
don't really see anything but then it
kind of like slowly pans over and close
up and then there it looks like a figure
standing there it's like really creepy
the way they did it
so this kind of goes on like this for a
while
june is starting to feel like um you
know a lot of stuff starts coming out
about
um how june feels bad because she was
never as close to her daughter as she
might have been and now she's gone and
like she feels like it's too late
so she almost feels like she's getting
another chance to like talk to her
because she's still like in the house
apparently
and then
you come to find out and like i said
spoiler alert this is your last warning
you come to find out
that all the stuff that you've seen like
the photograph in the backyard like the
um some of the video footage that
because matthew starts leaving um his
cameras running like in the house like
along the hallway and it catches like
figures and things like that
you find out about halfway through the
movie that matthew
was faking all of these uh
manifestations basically he was either
um one thing and he explained like how
he did it he's like you know i would
either take the photograph and he would
double expose it like with an old photo
of his sister
or he would have some old video of her
and then he would put it like in a
mirror and stuff like that and then he
would record it so it would look like
her ghost was like sitting in the room
or something like that
so it turns out
that matthew has been faking all the
[__]
now
so the mom is like bummed out
because
matthew said that he didn't really do it
to hurt his mom's feelings he did it
because
he felt like his mom wasn't getting
didn't get any closure because she
didn't see the body
and so he thought that if
the mom thought that
that alice wasn't really dead like if
she was still hanging around like they
would get the body exhumed she would see
it and then they would be able to like
get closure they'd be able to move on
with their lives and stuff like that
so
so the mom is like really devastated by
this because she's like oh well now
alice really is gone and now she felt
really bad about not being able to say
anything to her when she still thought
her ghost was around
and then there's yet another twist while
the mom is watching this faked footage
that matthew did of this ghost walking
down the hall
she notices
that there is another figure which you
didn't see the first time it was there
but you didn't like see it because you
were so busy looking at this like
supposed ghost over here
she sees this figure crouching in her
daughter's room
and she says
i thought it was alice but it's not it
was our neighbor
he was crouching like in the thing so
she's like what the [__] is that guy
doing in our house
so then they kind of start going through
and it turns out
that alice when she was alive she had
babysat for the neighbor and his wife
for several years and it turns out that
for the past couple of years the
neighbor and the wife
were essentially having a sexual
relationship with alice even though she
was only 14 when she started uh
when she started babysitting over there
so why the guy was in the house was that
there was a videotape of it of all the
three of them having sex right and so he
was like looking for it but he didn't
find it like the mom found it because
she saw where he was like uh crouching
this is becoming too much of a
temptation
she just can't stand she can't stand it
she can't stand it yeah
yeah so then that whole thing happens
like you know so they find out and so
the whole thing about this story is that
nobody knew alice at all like while she
was alive because no one had any idea
that this had been going on for two
years um she had been very so that's
like a lot a large part of the plot is
like this kind of like family
and um the fact that this girl
was like alone and like she didn't like
nobody knew her and nobody knew what was
going on in her life not her family not
her friends nobody seemed to know
anything because she kept everything to
herself so they not only find out that
but they also find out that she had gone
to the same psychic that her mom
uh went to later on but the psychic
hadn't told them that he said well i
wanted to keep it like confidential and
i thought i wouldn't be able to help you
and blah blah blah but when they found
like the footage of her like talking to
the psychic she said that she
had premonitions and dreams that she was
going to die
so then they find out through one of her
friends
like that they had gone out like on this
school trip to lake mungo hence why the
which is i guess is a real place but
that's um you know hence the name of the
movie
so they found out they had gone out
there on a school trip and she had been
acting kind of weird or she had gotten
really upset and nobody knew what she
was upset about so they had like some
phone footage of all the people like
running around having a good time or
whatever and they seemed and they caught
phone footage of alice
looking like she was burying something
like in the dirt like under this tree
out at lake mungo while she was on this
trip
so her family decided to go out there
once they see this footage
and see what it was that she buried out
there
so they go out there they dig in the
hole they find this bag
and in it is like a bunch of her like
most prized possessions like some
jewelry-ish that she loved and
everything and her cell phone is in
there this was in 2008 so it wasn't like
a smartphone it was like a you know like
a little kind of more flip phone but it
took video it was just real shitty
so they find the her phone
and they watch the footage on it
and it turns out and this was like one
of the creepiest things like when i
watched it the first time and a lot of
people were like really creeped out by
the footage that she captured on her
phone
it turned out that when she was out at
lake mungo which was a little while
before she drowned
she was out walking and she was like
filming
and she sees a figure like way off in
the distance
and she's filming and filming as she
gets closer and closer and closer and
then you see that the figure
is her
and it's her like the dead body like
when they pulled the dead body out and
she was all drowned and bloated and
everything so she basically saw a
doppelganger like of her dead body
out there and she knew that she was
going to die so this whole time she's no
she's
knowing that like something is
approaching and like something something
is coming together
so they find that out
and then for some reason like after that
trip like the family's like you know we
decided we finally came like we had some
closure we had we came back to the house
and it seemed like a lot better
so they decide that they're gonna move
and like you know go into the next
chapter of their lives or whatever and
then it turns out in the final twist
that when they show all of the faked
like footage and photos and everything
that matthew had done before like here's
the fake alice over here that he put
into the photo and then it pans over and
then she's really there so her ghost was
actually there the whole time
and
it's almost kind of like the reason that
i say this movie is really sad
is because
nobody knew alice while she was alive
and then after she was dead
you know they thought that her ghost was
there and then she wasn't there but then
it turned out that she actually was
there but they thought she wasn't so
it's like they left her
in the house all alone and that was kind
of like there was a scene where oh my
goodness don't do it
yeah she got mad
yeah i heard that right
keep trying to tear up those envelopes
now she wants to play on her back come
on get me
see she does this [__] because she knows
it will get a reaction from me this is
yeah she she knows like if she does
something bad daddy will come down and
like yeah and wrestle and wrestle with
her to get her to stop doing what she's
not supposed to be doing and i
accidentally trained her to do
bad things see i told you i should have
just ignored it or taken [__] away
instead i reacted and she loves the
reaction because that's like a play you
know yeah and she's ah she loves it
well yeah that's what i told you this
like when she was a kitten still yeah
like she knew
almost get a rise out of me yeah she all
she had she knew all she had to do was
go to the window that's like right next
to his side of the bed and like start
bashing on the yeah on the blinds
just like she used to get up on the dvd
shelf and like pull them out and like
fling them across the room because she
didn't like how much of a noise it made
she won't yeah she wants me to [__]
get down and wrestle with it she's well
she's just like a human child
that like if you pay too much attention
to them when they do bad things they'll
just do bad things all the time because
they've learned that that's how and
she's not a kitten she's three yeah
even though she's very small yeah she's
but you know she's very small
three-year-old she's just loves to
[__] play
but yeah so that's so that's why i think
that's why i think this movie is so sad
is just because
this girl who you never get to know
because basically at the beginning of
the mockumentary
she's you know they're talking about her
in the past tense like she's already
died so you never really get to know her
you only get to hear her voice a little
bit like on videotapes like near the end
and it's like you only see pictures and
like kind of silent footage of her so
it's kind of like she's this mis this
mystery
and then like as it goes on
and you find out that she had been going
through this [__] where she actually saw
her [__] dead doppelganger like i
don't think and knew that she was gonna
die and she was like dealing with that
she didn't tell anybody she was dealing
with like the sexual abuse from the
neighbors and didn't tell anybody there
was like all this kind of [__] that was
going on in her life and she didn't feel
that she could tell anybody
and then she dies
and then you know you know like i said
the the ghost being fake but then she
turned out she really was there
but she still wasn't able to connect
with them like you know what i mean they
just kind of like okay well i guess
she's not there we're gonna move on with
our lives and they left and there's like
a shot at the end where like the three
of them are like posed in front of the
house and like in the window of the
house you can just barely see that there
may be a figure there like she's
watching and she's watching as they
leave so it's kind of like she's kind of
doomed to like be stuck in this house
forever and now her family is gone so
she like has no more like so it's like
it's a really really sad
uh ghost story but yeah it's just like
like i said if you're not if you're not
into like real slow burn stuff like you
ghost story stuff this isn't like you
know um
jump scare kind of like monsters there's
nothing like that it's just like a
really good it's like a really really
creepy
episode of unsolved mysteries where
ghosts are real you know what i'm saying
like it's it's kind of structured like
that so a lot of it's just like
interviews just like a real documentary
would be
of them like talking about and then it's
like intercut with um you know
documentary footage news footage um you
know photos like creepy [__] but like i
said i think that makes it
eerier like more unsettling because it
seems like a lot more real than
something that's like over the top that
had people like flying around or
anything like that um
so yeah i just
like i said it's on to be if you want to
watch it i you know i spoiled it so i
hopefully you've already watched it
well like i said it's hard to talk about
if you can't talk about like all the
twists and turns in it
um because that's kind of like a big
part of its appeal i think but as i said
it's i really liked going into it the
first time i saw because i've seen it a
couple times now i thought it was kind
of long i thought it was kind of dry um
but
like i said you know enjoying a movie a
lot of it has to do with down mindset at
the time
maybe if i was in a different mood i
would have liked it better but in
general this isn't my kind of movie
anyway yeah um i like stuff that's
funny or
you know more over the top
yeah and this is more like
this is like i said it's like realism
it's kind of dry i feel like if you
liked um the haunting of hill house you
would probably dig this because um
it's very much an exploration of grief
like how people um react when
someone they love has died and they kind
of and all the conflicting emotions that
they have about that there's a lot of
[__] shitty blair witch prodig
project kind of rip-offs and i wouldn't
put this in that this is nothing like
that like that although i'd say
it's kind of like the blair witch in a
way well yeah in the sense that it's
like a mockumentary and i really like
the mockumentary format because i find i
feel like mockumentary is almost kind of
like a subset of found footage but
um it's not exactly the same because
when you do a mockumentary you're trying
to make it appear as though it's
something that really happened whereas
found footage is more like
well you know here's a videotape that we
found and we're like showing it to you
you know what i mean so it's like kind
of similar but not really
um but this is easily one of my favorite
mockumentary films this and the bay uh
were actually really good and the bay
might might be on 2b2 i'm not really
sure i don't remember where i saw that
but that's another one that's like a
mockumentary but this is this is the
most
the this is the uh most
you [__] [__] up
she knocked that over and the purse went
flying yeah she knows that she's trying
to get a damn reaction out of me
yeah come here poop well she it's
working yeah it's working
because that's like i can't even yeah
she really she
making me mad is like a game to her yeah
she thinks that she knows i won't hurt
her but she wants me to what she tries
to do sometimes and she gets in this
[__] move where she wants me to get
so mad that i chase her yeah that's what
she wants yeah she knows how to get her
eyes out of me yeah
you're driving me crazy
and she doesn't get it she's like she's
over there with her little tail wagging
wagging you she's like i don't know if i
can break you she's yeah
she's yeah she's very good at that yeah
but yes this is this is the most
realistic mockumentary i've ever seen
it's almost if like i said if you didn't
know that this wasn't something that
really happened you would think that it
really happened because it really just
the actors [__] sell it man they they
really seem like just real people the
news footage looks like real news
footage the [__]
kind of shitty
um
you know video footage which is it's
shitty but it's like realistically
shitty not like oh look we made it look
specifically shitty for this found
footage movie you know because there's
kind of a fine line between
because you know how many shitty found
footage movies there are and there there
comes a point where you can take it too
far it's almost like wanting it to look
like found footage so he was like we
should eat it up but this isn't really
like that this seems like a lot more
realistic and like i said to me that
makes it creepier because
it's almost like
it reminds me of
unsolved mysteries a little bit just in
the way or maybe one of the newer
netflix documentaries and reminds me of
haunting of hill house a little bit in
the sense that um
it's
kind of like somebody is haunted by
a doppelganger of themselves which also
kind of happened in haunting of hill
house because she kept seeing another
spoiler alert uh
that the one character kept seeing the
bentneck lady which turned out to be her
like after she was dead like it hung
herself with a broken neck and
everything so uh that's but as far as i
know this is the only two things that
have really explored that and i wish
more things would explore doppelgangers
because i always found doppelgangers
like really really creepy like david
lynch seems to do that type of thing a
lot which is probably why it creeps me
out so much but um
i don't know they don't do it much in
movies and i wish they would do more of
it because i always found it really
scary
and this uh this particularly like the
one scene where she's like going towards
it and then she sees what it is and they
freeze on it it's like pretty freaky but
yeah so definitely
if this sounds like something that you
would be into
uh i really really do recommend this
i've seen it two or three times and it's
really really good um but as you said
it's not
it's not big jump scare it's not a
monster movie it's nothing like that
it's just very
it's very subdued um very creepy just
really really good movie and i feel like
it's really underrated so uh definitely
go and check it out and we will see you
next time bye